[Music]
it's a beautiful day in this
neighborhood beautiful day for a
neighbor
won't you be mine
could you be mine
it's a neighborly day in this beauty
wood
a neighborly day for this beauty
won't you be mine
could you be mine
i have always wanted to have a neighbor
just like you
i've always wanted to live
in a neighborhood
with you
so let's make the most
of this beautiful day
since we're together
we might as well say
would you be mine could you be mine
won't you be my neighbor
won't you be
won't you please
please won't you be
my subscriber
hi there subscriber
feeling uncomfortable
[Music]
strangers
[Music]
all right glad to be with you it always
gets a laugh out of edward the sound guy
it does it's very easy to get a laugh
out of him the king of the dad jokes the
dad jokes
and uh there's just a couple of just a
couple of hip thrusts uh glad to be with
you this is the thursday live stream
it's available on youtube and facebook
for free that's the sound of the weekend
i should say this is a sound of the
weekend bruising with me in video studio
as always is jared who is not gay follow
him on twitter at not gay jared i
fulfill my legal obligations draw your
own conclusions
the reason it's mixed me up is because
we're daily now a lot of people are
saying this for free
and they're probably confused confused
because they get it both on seer tv at
nine right live here on thursdays at
eight yeah
or they're listening on itunes or
listening on soundcloud so don't worry
this is always going to be free we're
always gonna have awesome guests and
segments but uh it's a little bit
shorter because we're doing it every day
monday through thursday now and then
starting in february not gay jared and
courtney and uh some others behind the
scenes will have their own show
so uh glad to be with you we have a lot
of news to get to we're going to have
matt iceman on tonight who just won this
he won this week right jordan he did he
won the celebrity apprentice contest
this week also he won't say it he's
relatively right-wing he's a good
patriot loves his country chael was
going to be on
who lost who lost but won his place but
everyone is placed back he's just it's
tough to hate shale and and uh
what else we'll have chill next week
chill got sick so chill we hope for a
speedy recovery and um we'll find out if
you're really sick because matt eisemann
will let us know
uh we're going to
tear reza oslon a new um gosh i'm trying
to think of the term that would apply
uh
genital generally mutilated orifice
right that would work for that's great
for muslims that would be relatable uh
reza azlan we'll talk about that after
the break uh he did some videos for vox
vox's full-scale pro-islamic propaganda
this week this week especially seems to
come on strong again they seem to be
coming on really strong i think that's
their new tact with trump because
repealing the affordable care act people
actually want to yeah and so i think now
they're like oh gosh wow a second
actually a lot of people voted for him
and there are more people even people
who didn't vote for him who like some of
his policies let's uh say he's racist
and islam and now they're like ah look
look look anti islam islam is peaceful
let's bring out reza oslon who claims
he's not gay but
come on now um
so we'll be talking about that before
that though we're going to talk about
seth meyers of course and fake news fake
news has been all the rage this week
uh a couple of things more fallout here
from the cnn buzzfeed disaster
it's now been shown that trump was not
briefed i think we can bring this up
here on the infamous two-page addendum
so we know that now for a fact
so before it was like ah it's
uncorroborated we don't know we know now
for
sure that cnn went with verifiably false
information but it wasn't us it was
buzzfeed okay
you're in good company cnn uh senator
took the first step to repeal obamacare
last night 51-48 vote also there's a
bunch of stuff going on with jeff
sessions as to whether he's a racist or
not but i'm sure you've heard about that
everywhere else we've written about it
at a lot of credit.com but that's
actually pretty boring
so
i know my rep scott he's such a policy
wonk he wanted me to talk about jeff
sessions i was like i just don't i don't
care i know it's going to be a lifetime
movie at some point
that's the cliff no version on uh yeah
jeff sessions will be the racist in the
south and he'll be pushing his wife down
a flight of stairs because that always
happens in lifetime movies
and uh you guys have enough information
on that what i do want to get to is seth
meyers we were all watching this when we
were prepping for today's show we just
couldn't
i mean
the irony is so rich you could get gout
in an incredible twist
um he did a big bit yesterday
on fake news well first he tried to take
the moral high ground and take a cnn
and buzzfeed to task so let's show that
first in his defense he did do that last
night cnn published this bombshell
report intel chiefs presented trump with
claims of russian efforts to compromise
him but then today nbc news contradicted
that story reporting that donald trump
wasn't told about unverified russian
dossier now buzzfeed also reported on
this story but handled it very
differently publishing the 35-page
dossier that detailed the unverified
allegations and it's worrisome to
publish allegations like this without a
shred of evidence look nobody wants to
believe that trump paid russian hookers
to pee all over a bed more than i do
but there is zero proof that happened
well exactly and and now there's proof
that it didn't happen yeah or there's
proof at least that the people who ran
with it had no proof that it happened
they very usually that means you likely
lied when you run with a story as a
journalist that you verifiably have no
way to prove so i agree with seth meyers
here i agree with him and he seems to be
talking about how this is a problem in
in news so it seems like he might be
consistent we're on board
today trump called these new reports
fake news so despite an incredibly short
run i think it is time to retire that
term it used to be one thing but now
everyone is using it for everything fake
news as a term is busted
what
well that's your term
fake news is over now apparently
they want you to know that fake news is
so over
right it's it's it's it's it's because
it's the uncle it's you fake news is a
thing because of you i get it right fake
adjective news noun it was just an
objective and announced it shouldn't
really mean much but for the longest
time recently fake news has been a buzz
term fake news in quotes to mean anyone
who disagrees with the mainstream press
to mean anyone who's conservative you
see it with zuckerberg talking about how
they need to clamp down on fake new fake
news uc vox uc salon paul krugman at the
new york times they were all talking
about fake news and look look at every
single picture when they're talking
about fake news they show republicans
they show conservatives they show any
kind of right-leaning website that was
the term fake news because they wanted
to blame this election not on their
shortcomings not on the kind of debacles
that you see right now with cnn and
buzzfeed they wanted to blame it on fake
news out there now we've actively fought
against clickbait for a long time and on
our website we reference everything we
source everything if we do a video like
even right now these references are
available to you you can see the urls i
understand
fake news is bad but the term the
colloquialism fake news is because of
you seth meyers do we have the buzzfeed
buzzfeed buzzfeed even ran a piece
top six ways is it a video or is it a
it's it's a webs it's a website can we
see it yeah i got it right article
buzzfeed these six easy steps will help
you spot fake news every time
step step one
does it come from buzzfeed
again here's the thing
if if buzzfeed did not get caught
if if cnn did not get caught
today
they would still be running with fake
news today they'd still be using the
term it was all over every single panel
every single show on primetime fake news
was a real problem van jones yeah i have
emotional whiplash from fitness well
fake news is the problem what do we do
the principal press as mello street
talked about it the principal press the
one who the ones who ran with this story
who seth myers is now condemning and
using as the fulcrum for saying let's do
away with fake news they're the ones who
created the colloquialism
buzzfeed you can clearly see
buzzfeed
do you not do you not unders these are
here's the problem with liberals now
they're children who've never been
spanked and put to bed
and and as much we know we i opposed
donald trump and some policy issues i do
love that he is bending them over his
knee
and he's telling them who their daddy is
in the sense that
okay you want to run on fake news all
right listen donald trump has published
some conspiracy theories that are
uncorroborated donald trump is an
offender that i understand that as well
but these other people have lost the
moral high ground but i and that's why i
find it so funny because seth meyers was
just i mean he was always talking about
fake news he's a leftist who championed
the cause by the way we're not using
these sites because they're not
mainstream if you ever watch samantha
bee her references are nearly always
salon
and vox and ironically no unironically
and i'm pretty sure that seth meyers
uses the same crew he just doesn't show
his his sources but i do wonder all of a
sudden right seth meyers uh has decided
he needs to
pivot away from so fake news is is done
it's a term but you've been pushing it
for months
why could seth meyers why is he upset
now about fake news when he was pushing
why
hold on
is there a reason
is it possible
the intelligence community uh briefed
both the president and the
president-elect with allegations
that the russian government has
compromising information nobody has
sourced it so where are we based on an
mi6 british investigative right also
says that hillary clinton the groups
that wanted hillary clinton to win may
have been behind the investigations
themselves the the press report was
about them
going to the president and it says that
they never briefed him on it believe it
said they did brief him on it well he
has said that he is not aware of that
okay that concerns me
[Music]
so the same thing
i just want to make this clear seth
myers [ __ ] about fake news buzzfeed
tells you how to spot fake news buzzfeed
runs a fake story cnn runs it and seth
meyers not only brings it up on his show
it wasn't part of the monologue for some
jokes i understand that right sometimes
you pick some topics we're like and this
is weak but it's funny material he
grilled
a direct a direct employee was that the
term employee of donald trump would we
say yeah he grilled a direct sir a
direct associate of donald trump
repeatedly repeatedly and insinuated
that she was lying in what now we know
it turns out to be an entirely
vindicated stance she was right seth
meyers was wrong he was running with
this as news asking kellyanne conway now
that it's wrong today let's do away with
fake news right like the hipsters they
are fake news is over people i'll tell
you what for us it's not but as far as
leftists having the moral high ground
and accusing everyone else like us here
being fake news you might have that
right
that's over
that's over
[Music]
dormio
hey no hopper you're not supposed to be
on there get off get off that's the new
door meow i i know it's soft and
comfortable on your back
go
hello mattress my old friend
i've come to lay with you again
[Music]
because a vision i was dreaming
of you and i together sleeping
and the comfort
that was planted
in my brain
still remains
within the sound
[Music]
of silence
[Music]
dormi dormio mattresses
sleepwithcrowder.com
for specials and free shipping and a
pillow
[Music]
all right glad to be back matt eisemann
from celebrity apprentice coming up
later after this break
so we have a lot to get to uh okay
marley was dead to begin with let me
start with this
reza oslon
who's one of the biggest islamic
apologists you see out there on cable
news has somehow gotten a pass as though
he's an intellectually
uh honest or critical thinker who
presents very compelling arguments for
islam we had so many people saying why
don't you have him on it's very hard
we'll have our booker come on with the
list of people who've refused to do the
program reza oslon is a social justice
warrior personified this is what i would
like to presuppose reza oslon is not an
intellectual he's a social justice
warrior just like a lacey green just
like a bernie sanders just like a vox
and um
i think by the end of this segment uh i
can prove it to you let's roll the first
clip you are according to the fbi more
likely to die as the result of faulty
furniture than by an islamic terrorist
so
you should really be scared of your lazy
boy
okay so right away you should be
starting to see the similarities this is
an argument
no no this argument is intellectually
lazy
boy see what i did there i see this is
so this is this is it's obviously it's
such an intellectually lazy argument
okay a couple of things first off i
don't know what kind of numbers you're
using because barack obama's farewell
address he just said that there were no
known terrorist attacks on american soil
uh under his watch that things were
better that global terrorism was down i
don't know fort hood chattanooga boston
bombers so maybe those aren't being
included where he's talking about the
unlikelihood of a terrorist attack
globally they occur all the time every
day people are killed in the name of
islam at very very high record numbers
consistently so i don't know the numbers
that he's using there but
let's remove that from the table okay
i'm going to give him as much leeway as
possible
a lazy boy a piece of furniture is an
inanimate object
it doesn't have
an evil ideology it doesn't have a
violent ideology that's like saying well
statistically uh it's very unlikely that
you will be sexually there there are not
many pe you're more likely to drown in
the pool johnny than be raped by a
pedophile so
just don't walk by the pedophile's house
you can't fix
random furniture breaking and
i don't know where he's buying his
furniture yeah i'd say maybe ikea
probably maybe ikea well the swedes
they're overrun with the islamists it
would make sense plus liberals love ikea
they do
uh there you have it
sorry i'm gonna stop with the swedish
meatballs jokes i could just go into the
swedish chef gag here's the deal with
that anyone who's watching this if you
want to think this is someone who is
intellectually genuine
do you really think he's dumb enough to
not see what a horrible comparison that
is that's that's not a valid analogy
chairs
furniture
they do not have an ideology that can
kill people islam does in record numbers
so don't try and compare them next clip
i grew up in a predominantly mexican
community so i just told everybody i was
mexican
oh practicing islamic takea as a toddler
very nice for those who don't know look
up islam takea next clip hardest part
for me when i'm
being interviewed is to
temp down my astonishment the question
at the bottom of the screen that
everyone is looking at does islam
promote
violence the thing that's mostly going
through my mind is calm down calm down
the justice system in muslim countries
you don't think is somehow more
primitive or subjugates women more than
in other countries
did you hear what you just said you said
in muslim countries
yes
yes she did this is another tactic of
the social justice warrior just act like
it's so absurd oh
so you like people could vote for donald
trump and they're not racist did you see
what you just said
let me fade a fence with my uh with my
perfectly strand plucked eyebrows it's a
perfectly valid question
as a matter of fact i think it's a
necessary question
muslim countries now that you should be
happy about this reza azlan she's not
saying all muslims hashtag not all
muslims she's saying as a general rule
in islamic countries do we acknowledge
that maybe there's a systemic problem in
their treatment of women let alone gays
let alone people who aren't muslim we'll
get to that in a moment she is saying as
a general rule in the islamic world does
it stand to reason your honor to say
that they have not stepped up with the
rest of the modernized world in western
society
[Music]
and he acts as though that's an
unreasonable question well uh what about
the fact that i think we have these
sources 85 percent globally and muslim
believe that women should always obey
husbands try and tell that to mtv
feminist news and see what they think
about if you were to say christians did
it 53 believe women can be punished for
not wearing veils more than half the
muslims in the world believe women
should not have the right to divorce or
equal rights to inheritance
these here's the point these are not
extremists these are statistics
verifiable statistics across the islamic
world does that mean that there aren't
variances between say indonesia where
actually they might be pretty nice to
women but there's record church burnings
as it occurs with christians right now
but we don't talk about that no it
doesn't mean that of course pakistan's
going to be worse and saudi arabia may
be worse with gay people and the uae may
be worse with rape we understand that
there are variances across the islamic
world but for her to ask the question as
a general rule hashtag not all muslims
are equal rights of problem the islamic
world and reza azlan wants you to
believe that that is an unreasonable
question that can be attributed well to
something that social justice warriors
constantly accuse their opponents of and
we'll get to that let's go to the next
clip please don't generalize about 1.7
billion people in the world
okay let's not
let's not generalize about 1.7 how about
1.2 billion
how about 1.2 billion people in the
world i've got some statistics here we
did a video on this ben shapiro did a
great video on this uh we have 52
percent of american muslims who support
some form of sharia law a quarter of
american muslims the most moderate in
the world support jihad then if you look
in other countries like pakistan you
have 75 percent of people who support
strict sharia law over two-thirds
support honor killings you can go across
the spectrum you can go to saudi arabia
you can go to pakistan you can go to
indonesia you can go to malaysia you can
go to uae you can go to iran you can go
to egypt you'll find these numbers
pretty consistent
at least 20 something percent of muslims
if they aren't and of course aren't
engaged in terrorism but actively
support terrorist organizations or
believe that it's justified
so 1.2 million 1.2 billion muslims who
believe in some form of sharia law or
death for apostasy right
we know that now i know you'll say well
sharia law it's not the same in every
okay that's true let's allow for some
variances sharia law generally has some
pillars that are pretty important
meaning divitude subjugation of people
who are non-muslim meaning women are
treated differently from men under the
law meaning non-muslims are treated
differently under the law meaning gay
people tend to be stoned to death
meaning women need certain people for
rape meaning there is death for apostasy
those are generally considered i know
there's different sharia law but if you
look across the board as a general rule
hashtag not all muslims those tend to be
included in sharia law
let's go conservatively 1.2 let's take
that back let's take it to less than
half let's say 500 million muslims in
the world believe in sharia law or 500
million muslims believe in honor
killings or death for apostasy we know
guaranteed it's much higher than that
i'm saying let's scale back 1.2 billion
let's scale it back to 900 let's scale
it back to 500 million muslims on planet
earth who believe in implementing laws
that violate basic fundamental human
rights
that's not a problem
am i making a generalization with 500
million people the westboro baptist
church who are talked about every time
they send out a press release
have about 16 members and two of them
have flippers next clip you're a muslim
so why did you write a book about the
founder of christianity
well to be clear i am a scholar of
religions with four degrees including
one in the new testament and fluency in
biblical greek
to be fair
that was an incredibly stupid question
that question was everything that is
wrong with cable news
i worked at fox news for four years i've
appeared at every cable network known to
man and i agree that that was an
incredibly stupid question
uh it was a leading question it was
irrelevant
that's one for you aslan
after about 10 years of being cable
news's favorite muslim
i've come to the realization that i
don't think it's doing any good bigotry
is not a result of ignorance it's a
result of fear and fear
is impervious to data fear is impervious
to information
oh okay
do you see it there i know when i said
reza aslan is a social justice warrior a
lot of people who are still in their
conversion process from the young turks
no
no i don't want to no
didn't want to believe he's an
intellectual did you see what he did
he did the exact same thing every social
justice leftist does he said i used to
do it but now i absolve myself of the
requirement to make intellectual
arguments because
all of my opponents anyone who disagrees
with me are bigoted bigotry is
impervious to information do you see
what he just did it was the same thing
that the obama supporters did with the
tea partiers the same thing that hillary
supporters and bernie people did with
donald trump supporters the same thing
the social justice warriors do online
which is if you disagree with me you're
racist reza oslon someone who has been
held out as the pinnacle of intellectual
discussion regarding islamic
apologetics just said i no longer need
to argue my point because everyone who
disagrees with me is a bigot i could
rest my case here but let's go further
in this country we went from
overwhelming majorities who were against
same-sex marriage to overwhelming
majorities supporting same-sex marriage
within the span of a couple of years
right okay so when has that span of a
couple years occurred anywhere in the
islamic world yet reza aslan
mr mr left i know i know you're
incredibly add to israel and support
palestine how did your uh your meeting
with the hamas committee go did they
notice your lisp
per chance
i noticed you're still intact so i guess
not uh let's go through statistics
turkeys violent homophobia of course
hate crimes against gay people that if
it occurred anywhere uh in in the modern
world it would be all over youtube and
facebook and they wouldn't even remove
it as fake news uh saudi arabia they
pushed for gays to be executed
bangladesh let's look there that's a
country i think
azlan has used as one of his examples
for moderate islam um
what are there 13 islamic countries that
officially 13.
so i get it hate crimes at parades and
stuff you know that you can't that's
anecdotal again let's give let's give
reza aslan as much leeway as possible
all those hate crimes that occur against
gay people in record rates that don't
occur in the modern world let's remove
those still 13 islamic countries that
kill you for um being a sprite
so uh he praises that here in the united
states
why don't you go out of your way to talk
about where it's still a problem
he seems he seems very obsessed with the
gay issue too constantly defending it so
a lot of articles but you know what
maybe he's just a compassionate person
next clip what changed people's minds
was will and grace
was modern family was watching people
who were gay
on television
being you know normal they're struggling
with the same issues that you're
struggling with they are human beings
and so for the last few years i've
decided that what i'm gonna do is try to
change people's minds through pop
culture through film and television
ah there it is and it's a great point
it's a great point from reza aslan it
also serves to debunk the idea that
conservatives or anyone who's not a
social justice warrior or some crazy
conspiracy theorist when they believe
that the entertainment industry and
media are colluding against their values
here you go
straight from the islamic horse's
possibly gay mouth
letters
thank god he's not clock boys all i'm
saying because they've got deep legal
pockets apparently he sold the stuff on
etsy so
watch last night's episode you'll
understand what i'm talking about reza
oslon here says
i am going to use for will and grace uh
you know modern family he says hollywood
serves to brainwash people hollywood
serves to act as prop because here's the
deal right is he using hollywood to
bring people together does he want to
use pop culture to bring people together
no he doesn't because he just dismissed
half of the entire country is bigoted
and racist remember that
so what does he want to do he wants to
use pop culture media news to dismiss
and brainwash everybody into believing
that all these people are racist and
they're bigoted and they're homophobic
and they're transphobic so let's put
more [ __ ] in superwoman let's put
more uh let's put more uh gay people and
i don't know any single show let's
whatever it is at every single turn they
have to put something in there to inject
a social justice we need more
superheroes who are black we need more
female superheroes who have hijabs we
need to do that because now pop culture
so they're they're they're framing you
all as bigoted this islam the great
intellectual islamic thinker people who
disagree with me are bigoted really
maybe people who disagree with you it
doesn't mean they're bigoted if they
disagree with passages in the quran that
say kill infidels wherever you find them
surah 4 34 i could rattle off some
verses for you
is it me does it mean they're bigoted if
they're let's say they don't even have
an opinion but they're a bit concerned
that according to hadith muhammad called
for the deaths of christians and jews as
his last words does it mean you're
bigoted if muhammad beat his
six-year-old wife does it mean you're
bigoted if muhammad came out and said
you know what i think i was wrestling
with a demon and his wife said no that
was that was an angel and that's how the
religion started is it bigoted if
christians maybe go listen i think this
is a perversion of the christian faith
or even jewish people who say you know i
think this is a version of the old
testament because they think that
everything after abraham's blessing was
a lie is it bigoted for people to have
any kind of apprehensions with islam
reza oslon says yes that can be the only
reason and he is going to serve the rest
of his life brainwashing the public to
ensure that they agree with him
ladies and gentlemen i rest my case
let's move on to the next story
a little lighter steve harvey
okay so steve harvey made this joke i
actually i know our ep scott doesn't
like steve harvey i i think he's funny i
think he's funny what do you think i
have always thought he's funny he's a
good host i think he's funny too i think
he's a good host um i mean i know he's
no bombing i know he's probably more
liberal and but i don't care i've
thought he's pretty funny
um
well let's just go this is what everyone
is mad about he made this joke finally
here's one
how to date a white woman a practical
guide for asian men
i know he's just doing the black thing
but i find it funny
that's one page too
excuse me
do you like asian men no
thank you
people got so offended by that
hugh huffpo outrage
jordan huffington post of course was
outrage steve harvey thinks the idea of
being attracted to an asian man is
laughable
um the media overreacted uh what was it
what was this one to the uh oh the blog
i guess this is pretty popular
angryasianman.com
is that the one that we found yeah sure
do we have it here's the funny thing do
we have the quote so
angryasianman.com wrote about how this
is unacceptable and i'm reading a quote
directly from this blog
that's how a tv host can shamelessly
[ __ ] on asian man on national television
so in being offended by stereotypes he
perpetuates a stereotype let me read it
and probably he probably wrote it in his
inner monologue that's how a tv host can
shamelessly [ __ ] on asian man on
national tv
like dr ho with the you have to poop
every day buy my cleanse when you don't
go poop every day you feel bloated
sluggish uncomfortable
steve harvey you make me uncomfortable
you go poop on the asian man
the point is this he made a joke which i
thought was actually pretty funny yeah
it was funny i think your joke was far
more racist than steve harvey my joke is
definitely
and i'm not black so i don't have as
much of a pass send your letters i'm
fine with them i'm used to them at this
point
um
so everyone gets outraged right and
basically what they're doing i've had
this happen where huffpo literally
fact-checked my jokes
um so in this process they were
effectively fact checking the joke of
steve harvey which is a joke this is why
the left ruins comedy this is why the
best comedians i guarantee you out of
the next decade are not going to be left
at all no amy schumer not fun anymore
it's just she was funny now when she
decides to push an agenda it just gets
to be too much
um here's the deal what if when you're
fact-checking a joke the original joke
from steve harvey is actually more
accurate now this is going to be super
racist statistically so uh asian men
actually do have a tougher time dating
this comes from okay cupid
okcupid repeated that women penalized
asian men when making their selection
uh and non-black men
penalized asian women uh black women so
non-black men this is just the dating
profiles when they looked at it
non-black men so that could include
asians or white people they tended to
prefer people who were not black women
women tended to overwhelmingly prefer
men who were not asian when given the
choice does this mean that asians are
unattractive no does it mean that asians
are ugly no what it means that to most
women who are not asian
asian men will have a hard time dating
them this is a verifiable fact it's just
not a preference of most women who don't
happen to be asian some more these are
these are biological evolutionary
mechanisms for a lot of people uh there
are studies that we have here women are
attracted to men with higher
testosterone levels i think we found
this finally
um
do we have that link up there on the the
t-shirt study the sweaty t-shirt study
this one was was amazing to me so this
is where where smell knows no racial
background it knows no ethnicity it
knows no no social class they gave women
sweaty t-shirts from men who had worked
out and women innately preferred the
sweat
of uh for various t-shirts they prefer
to sweat from men who had higher
testosterone levels who had better
symmetry which is a sign of good
genetics these are things that women are
attracted to now the reason women tend
to not be attracted non-asian women tend
to not be attracted to asian men asians
tend to be smaller than the general
population physically they tend to be
smaller right so
by comparison women who aren't asian who
aren't smaller where it's a it's a
it's it's a more effective ratio asian
women asian men white women are a little
bit taller they tend to prefer bigger
men they tend for men who look like they
could physically provide strapping men
bigger joints early these are signs of
higher testosterone not signs that as a
general rule i know someone will send me
a picture of an asian bodybuilder a
general rule that asian men tend to have
as attributes on the flip side women
actually they tended to milo
yiannopoulos talked about this on the
show a lot of them liked black men these
same women
for the opposite reasons black men tend
to be taller black men tend to be
muscular black men physically tend to
have attributes that women find
effectively attractive and a mate on the
flip side men found asian women to
actually be pretty attractive it doesn't
say in the study if they found them more
attractive than white women but men on
average who weren't black found black
women less attractive as a general rule
black women tend to be bigger black
women tend to be stronger black women
for a lot of men men are looking for
women who they believe will carry on
their offspring most effectively we'll
be mothering will be nurturing look soft
look warm kind these are simply
statistics that people felt they had
certain perceptions of people from
different races when it came to dating
so long way around to say this steve
harvey made a joke it should have just
been a joke but because liberals fact
checked the joke we have to fact check
their fact checking of a joke and the
joke was more accurate than the outrage
by the way something that's ironic is
women completely change their tune on
asian men when they notice that they
have an average higher income so there's
a silver lining there's still the lining
for my dating life i no longer need to
feel ashamed sluggish disadvantaged
uncomfortable matt iseman coming up next
dr ho
[Music]
dormitory
and restlessly by toss along
on this old mattress made of stone
[Music]
nothing really rhymes with dormio
[Music]
but it's the best sleep
that i've ever
[Music]
mattresses sleepwithcrowder.com
for specials and free shipping and a
pillow
[Music]
reach the wizard
all right glad to have this next guest
he is a regular uh he's been on several
times one time he was actually uh
yelling at housekeeping because he was
doing it from a hotel so always very
bizarre locales now he's in his car so
uh this is i don't know how legal this
is uh don't answer that pulled over for
the record right that's what he's saying
yelling at somebody yes he'll still be
yelling at someone uh that's funny jared
you know it's funny he does the same
thing only not gay girl just yells at
the jews and i don't know why it can't
help it
i can't help it i'm a quarter jew you
can yell at me not guys well that
doesn't surprise me because you were a
doctor uh so we should introduce him at
matt eisemann at matt eisemann hashtag
celebrity apprentice he is on this
season of celebrity apprentice along
with her other good friend chael sunnin
who will also be on the program uh okay
matt knows this little inside baseball
chael was supposed to be on today and
then he said he was sick and matt was
supposed to be next week
so
uh you can give us you find out for us
if he's really sick
i i would love to know because i'm going
to his fight on the 21st against tina
ortiz and i don't want to half-ass uh
chill in the ring there i'm expecting
full full octane summit well you can't
get full octane because there's drug
testing um but
he's the first to admit it
i'm older than chael and that was one of
the questions i had for him was how good
are the drugs and he just said it was
remarkable the recovery time like how
much it would cut down yeah on recovery
time yeah and it's one of those things
where you know bannon athletics have a
level playing field whatever but but as
you age i think this the sense of using
these at lower doses you're not looking
for maximum performance sure but just
for recovery for like i look at my dad
he had knee surgery i'm like why are you
not on hgh yeah
it's been proven over the past few
decades to be unbelievably effective at
helping people recover from injury and
working and that's why they were created
like anavar is a steroid that they'll
give to people very common for wrestlers
they used to call it the wrestler
steroid because uh it wasn't like a
bodybuilding steroid it would lean
people out and help them with strength
but it wouldn't add muscle it wasn't you
know it was created i don't know if it
was created but it still is prescribed
to cancer patients and aids patients and
burn victims because of what it does for
we'll talk about that after the year i
know a guy mark rippetoe knows a guy i
have no doubt or chill um because of
what it does for collagen synthesis
right so that increa you know and these
people are tearing their ligaments so
yeah i'm i totally uh
agree as they get older in life but
again that's another issue that's kind
of been politicized uh another issue
that was just is your show celebrity
apprentice now you're at the epicenter
of this controversy
um what's the vibe like is it like
somebody died or is it like your former
boss is president
i i don't know it's surreal because we
you know when we shot it we shot it last
february and at that point
trump was very much a long shot and nbc
had several ties with him yeah he was
not at all involved the show it didn't
you know
it moved production from new york to la
there was you know he's you the talk of
him is speaking of professional
programming aim your camera down a
little bit matt we're professionals here
no not that now we don't just want to
see your chin
okay there we go that works better thank
you okay continue put it over here
i'm in my car this is oh uh yeah that
works yeah so
so trump uh he he had no involvement in
the show he was not involved in the
shooting there was no talks of him he's
not looking at daily cuts of the show
giving notes on production it was
supposed to air in september but i think
they felt that given the political
climate with the
uh with the election going on that it
was probably a more polarizing time so
they're like postpone it and i'm sure
in the back of their minds they're
thinking that
you know probably the situation would
resolve itself instead he wins
and then
oh it's like just time over that i've
got to imagine people there wait wait
wait what they they didn't know what to
do that totally changed their season
plans for the show
i i think so but but at the same point
you figure at that point it felt like
once the election happened people were
the
the daily discussion of polar i felt it
actually was less polarized once he was
elected yeah a lot of people made their
piece there were still obviously people
who felt this this is the apocalypse
personified yeah but with the show you
know again we we felt like the show was
still a separate entity and that you
know trump would be focused on being
president but then it came out he was
going to keep his name on his as uh an
executive producer and you know this in
entertainment he was involved in the
creation of the show he had the title in
the contract right he was going to get
his money either way he chose to keep
his name on it and that's well i think
he just can't ever see a power play well
he just can't stop winning
that's that's he keeps his name as the
executive
it distracts us all
but then but then you know the ratings
our first episode were up against the
bachelor and and football and and it
wasn't the ratings weren't as as good as
i think they were hoping for and so
shockingly then the the man who's
president-elect and who is
uh the ep on the show
then calls out our current boss arnold
schwarzenegger and at that point i was
just like this this is above my pay
grade i'm just happy to be involved in
the show and and honestly you know i i
think
that i
well here's something
it's not really fair i looked at a study
all shows uh were down by the same
percentage point from the last time the
celebrity apprentice premiered because
of how many people have shifted to hulu
so for example uh even if you look at
the bachelor i don't have the actual
numbers but if it was five million their
premiere like last season or two seasons
ago now it would be about 4.6 or 4.4 and
it was actually comparably not bad for
celebrity apprentice the ratings were
still good but a lot of people watch
these things on hulu i mean they call us
unpluggers so uh as much as trump keeps
winning he was a little bit absolutely
right that that the
the
the just the choices when you look at
like you said whether it's watching
streaming or fx with their programming
or hbo or showtime there's so many more
choices yeah more people are consuming
content but they're just doing it in
different ways so you're right yeah when
you look at a show 10 years ago what was
a hit it'd be 30 million people watching
it now seven million people is is a big
number yeah so you have kids doing that
on youtube channels playing video games
making fart noises right right it's
right which is essentially that's what i
do on celebrity apprentice that's all
you're looking for hours of fun
what do you do on your challenge
i like it for me i mean i'm looking over
your shoulder you've got the conan
crowder poster right there yeah
that's not good jared as red sonia there
oh i know it's so
it's it's amazing and to me sir i'm
getting notifications for me it's been
so awesome i i couldn't be a bigger
schwarzenegger fan i mean predator
commando terminator well you could be a
bigger fan if you were his maid there's
always the possibility of being a bigger
fan
boss i'm not laughing at you i'm like no
no hold on by the way just the most
unattractive woman like everyone watched
it and they're like okay there was some
story there either some scotch and
cigars or he was bored as hell but
army really sorry go ahead matt you have
to go back in the set i i
the the chance to work with
schwarzenegger made me
one of his biggest fans
and it was you know it was it was an
awesome show and and
the
a lot of people i i you know it's
unfortunate that i think this show has
become somewhat politicized because i
think it's an entertaining show and at
the end of the day look we're all on
there we're we're desperately looking
for more attention and um
for people to learn to learn us in a
different capacity but also we do get to
compete for charity and for me i have
rheumatoid arthritis i'm competing for
the arthritis foundation last week i got
to be project manager and i won and so i
raised 50 000 to the charity more
importantly you get to raise awareness
for for my story and for people yeah to
be aware of this charity so in the end i
feel like this i'm really proud to be a
part of this show and it's unfortunate
that it has become politicized well
unfortunately though you have to do all
this work for charity and since you're a
host for american ninja warrior you're
not making as much bank as some of the
other people so they i hope they're
tossing you on the side
at this point you know what the the real
it's it's it is this is a show
that i i think um you know the longer
you stay on the show you don't get more
money it really is just a chance to
promote your channel
funny enough the longer um arsenio hall
was on the show the less funny he got
so i'm hoping that you avoid that play
well
it's
is a hilarious guy but i will say like
being on the show
it it really is one of the more
stressful situations
certainly in hollywood it's been the
hardest thing i've done
since medical school because you really
are working on these tasks and you know
you're a competitor your pride kicks in
you don't want to lose you don't want to
be embarrassed you don't want to call
down the board
and then okay so that aside so donald
trump is president he's kind of been
insulting the show are you conflicted
with that as uh someone who i think
leans more politically right i don't
know you're kind of more central for me
i i look at it as as entertainment our
job is to entertain the show isn't a
political show with with apprentice it's
become politicized
no one's out there espousing you know
particular beliefs i i think it's i i
the goal for me as an entertainer is i'm
trying to reach as many people as
possible whether it's on american ninja
warrior or or celebrity apprentice or
social media and try to entertain them
and hopefully do some good so i think i
i think that
you know i i've seen on social media
people saying they won't watch the show
because of
uh the association with the previous
boss and i don't know that they would
watch the show have you had any people
the other way saying they won't watch it
because donald trump doesn't like you
now
i don't know
it's it's hard to know too because as
you know on social media a lot of people
are
just
saying things whether they would have
actually watched a show or wouldn't have
it's hard to know i i just feel you know
as someone who who is very apolitical as
a public figure i i i just i
i i i it's it's really sad to see
something that i thought was gonna uh be
a very positively perceived show other
than whatever where jackass is on the
show yeah make fun of that but to be
involved with something where people say
like i got an email from someone saying
you've you've betrayed the hippocratic
oath by being a part of the show and i'm
like
competing for yeah
it was a very i thought it was a very
big logical leap because again my mom
watched the show and when you were
project manager she got a heart attack
and it it literally
it was even before the show aired that
someone just wrote to me
as someone who has made you know who's
only tried to draw attention to the
arthritis foundation and it was so some
of those emails you're like okay yeah
delete you but you're not gonna let it
affect me it was it's unfortunate it was
sent from trump's doctor
it
by the way donald trump is the
healthiest president who's ever lived
you betrayed your hippocratic oath
your fake news all right uh
it's surreal you know i i don't know
that he's actually watching the show i
mean i would love for him to be but i
think he's probably busier
with things but it's tweeting
that that the president-elect
is involved you know with the show yeah
and and it's it is kind of a surreal
position as we see you know which i
think has been going on for years if not
decades just
the the merger between politics and
entertainment
and an opinion it's all coming together
good point uh at matt eisemann is the
best place for people to find you they
can watch you on celebrity apprentice
when does that air and where does it air
uh it's monday nights 8 p.m on nbc and
chael sonnen who i i like to think i
became friends with he's going to be um
he he's going to be fighting the 21st
i'm going to be out there
he'll be on the show here in the next
couple weeks oh jimmy smith yeah jimmy
smith well you know jimmy smith does the
the color commentary on bellator and he
and i work together on new warrior and i
just think he's one of the best
broadcasters around so i'm excited to be
there uh around jimmy as well so it's it
you know it's for me i i went and i was
a fanboy
american ninja warrior is pretty well
known i'm not i was not one of the
better known celebrities going into it
so you know to meet you but you look
better than cindy lauper
cindy lauper kind of looked like uh a
wax museum statue of cindy lauper
it's it's uh i've i'll be honest i look
we we did a viral videos for uh where we
were playing football with ricky
williams and boy george and carson
crusty and i'm looking at myself going
i'm not in football safe right now
to give me i need to get some squats
going or something i have a little gut
going well just just call uh call
chael's doctor and he'll fix you up in a
jiffy uh
matt eisenmann nbc uh celebrity
apprentice wednesdays at eight right
mondays mondays at eight i got that
wrong mondays at eight and uh if you
don't get your daily yes you don't have
to worry about days well if you don't
assuming you don't get terminated which
i come on uh if you don't get axed you
don't i won't say terminated again on
this show we will have you back to talk
about it and and and
and gossip and um i want to know
what kind of undergarments arnold
schwarzenegger wears today and i'm
betting that you can
i was trying to find out the whole time
i knew it he was the maid i was kissing
his ass
i'm shameless all right at matt eisen
thank you very much sir i think uh next
we're going to be reading tweets and uh
i don't know not kj is going to tell me
we'll see you soon congrats congrats on
always there shut up matt we're going to
a break
[Music]
hey jared what are you doing shooting
bad guys with what by r15 where'd you
get it
enunciate it more clearly so our
audience can hear
ar15.com that's better they sell guns
now yeah they do are they any good
they're the best where from air15.com
you really make that sound didn't have
the budget for sound effects
oh there's another one
you got him with what my air 15 from
where ar15.com hey how do you know
they're bad guys they're reds and burkas
that's racist
[Music]
that pretty often now thank you very
much for watching this is the last show
of the week starting in february not
jared and courtney have their own show
uh listen we've been having a daily show
all week this is the first week and uh
we can't tell you enough how
appreciative we are louder with
crowder.com mug club is where you go to
join louder with crowder.com mug club
it's 99
69 for the year if you're a student
military or veteran and that ends up
being less than six dollars a month and
we have a seven day free trial going on
right now so uh we're building we're
building everything out uh we have so
many more employees we're able to hire
more people we're able to have more
impact and it allows us to not be
beholden to facebook or youtube do not
have to do the click bait to not have to
cater to their every whim in order for
uh in order to get their advertising
dollars do we have the images jared of
who we uh we don't have those images but
we have these images what images oh
there you go well of course if you
subscribe to the mug club you get all of
crtv mark levin michelle malkin mark
stein myself and several other names
here coming up we're at about a
threshold where if you guys join you're
going to have uh pretty much a full day
of content there rounding out that clock
thank you so much uh well dormio is
another sponsor
dormio uh best mattress around but well
it is so awesome it's a sponsorship we
wanted
before we don't have the website up
right now but sleepwithcrowder.com if
you're listening to this the next
morning after the live show sleep with
credit.com you get an awesome deal a bed
that i think is usually two thousand
dollars for 13.99 free shipping to your
door free pillow money back guarantee um
i've had it for a while i got uh jared
knock aj one for christmas despite him
not deserving it and uh here's the thing
with any of the sponsorships with this
show
whether it's mug club or uh whether it's
a meal mattress we had prepare with
crowder.com
we never want to sell you anything that
you don't want we never want to be in
the business of pushing something that
you don't want but
any product or sponsor that you see on
this show has gone through extreme
vetting and what we want to do is
provide you with a value so think of us
as your groupon think of us as a place
where if you need a mattress uh go get
this mattress now could you get cheaper
mattresses uh
that would be perfectly adequate
probably
but if you want to get the best mattress
money can buy possibly and i mean way
better than the
the matches you hear on on am radio it's
a glorified inflatable bed with a with a
thing that goes like this so it's it's
dual zone uh
if you want to get you know exactly what
i'm gonna say then they were they were
using brand x brand
brand x
if you want the best matches possible
instead of spending twenty five hundred
500 getting fitted for one at a mall i
think it's 13.99 at sleepwriter.com and
it is awesome if you're in the market
for a mattress if not
don't uh don't spend any more than you
can afford lotto with credit.com mug
club so appreciative we are growing
leaps and bounds and it's all because of
you
thank you we'll be back
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to have that but i think
that uh that music doesn't sound super
loud to me this is years it's just my
ears okay uh this is a segment of the
show
where we have we put out a poll earlier
today and we're gonna read some of your
tweets so thank you very much we do the
facebook live stream uh just to interact
with you guys a little bit because we
have the guests on but they're not you
they can't replace you
you're a special jordan do we have the
results of the poll i do i have it right
up here on my screen let's bring some
juice up i think on jordan's mic unless
it's just me can you hear me i can hear
you fine but yeah is there does he need
more juice jared i need to get right
right on like that
all right go ahead so we had a poll that
went out who is the worst offender of
fake news
cnn
cnn uh or buzz buzzfeed option three
with cnn and buzzfeed uh option four was
russian hookers urinating what were the
results
forty-seven percent said both cnn and
buzzfeed oh
i don't do we have it up on the uh uh
joining us we send me a screen there
all right let's get you sent in the
screen here um
there we go there we go okay let's see
it
wow 13 said russian hookers peeing now
say what you want about russian hookers
peaking but um i don't think they've
ever actually been
charged with journalistic malpractice
i don't think so yeah they do that well
they do i will say this i find them
disgusting integrity
yes few industries but the russian being
the russian
that pissing everyone
now i i have my we're not they're
believe me i'm not without my qualms
with russian hookers urinating oh no
they're not without their faults plain
talking about there but dishonesty is
not amongst them no i think we're all in
agreement
uh do we have any other best tweets
jordan do you have up there
no he told us
hold on we have to take a couple of your
questions here uh hold on richard you
kiss your grandmother that mouth oh that
was tweeting someone who tweeted us
named richard someone sent us the joker
gift because they understand the brand x
jokes
brittany rose says stephen credit
promotes mattresses ben shapiro promotes
sheets i feel like they're sending a
message hey woe now
that's not fair because it's a sabbath
and ben can't be around to defend
himself that's some real illuminati crap
right there i i've got one here okay
it's from uh dick morris
oh no no no you're not we have no you
don't show his tweets
not gay jared he didn't fill jordan in
literally i didn't even read it does
that have something to do with feet
um
sure
since i'm finally reading my tweets can
you answer uh final answer the question
of why you hate me so much well no it
has to do with the feet yes dick morris
uh
way in here cnn is fiction says crunch
berries are lucky charms
real
milk and cereal is for babies real men
drink beer
that's a lucky charm for sure
well no doubt uh
hold on someone's really mad that we
said women found black men more
attractive they're saying black men at
the second lowest rating by women asian
males were the lowest how can we watch
lwc next week if it's not live on
youtube
right in nyc tweets um i feel like
you're trolling at this point
louder with credit.com mug club daily
crtv 9 pm every single day you get an
early stream on thursday so that they
can have it archived at uh sierra tv
they might have been they might even be
beginning the archive of this right now
as we finish it up so uh jordan do you
have any more to read one or two more
and then we will come in with the
clothes somebody had some speculation on
arnold's underwear which
isn't kind of goes without saying that
arnold goes commando oh daniel eldritch
you're you're incorrigible
you're tan
that's so daniel
such a daniel joke
i'm surprised edward didn't the sound
guy didn't laugh more at that
[Laughter]
he loves the dad jokes and he's like no
no boo
i do not approve of the sunglass
standards okay hold on one second i have
one more tweet to read and we're gonna
wrap this up
in i'm from vermont send help well we
know some other people who need some
help in vermont right now as well
can i
that's not funny to you only to us
uh
see there we go i know nothing like
inside jokes on the radio yeah another
legend said i'm sorry uh austin rica
asks can i put my mug in the dishwasher
uh the answer this has been this
technically you can't this is the first
mug ever
that was put out and as you can see it
has a chip on it because i this is the
first one we ever had and i've put run
this to the dishwasher a lot so you can
see the red is still on there there have
been a couple of people depending on
what kind of a solvent you use
depending on how your dishwasher gets
again keep in mind these are hand etched
hand painted hand etched and speckly and
speckly glorious quality item
lotto with credit.com club they're hand
edged hand painted so the hand painting
can run off depending on what you use in
the district girthy as hell they i know
i you know
say the the the mrs complains about it
in the morning because she prefers to
drink it out of a smaller cup she does
oh the cup cup yeah no we're there um
we're going to be shipped off to vermont
soon
that's the problem in our line of work
you're sure if you don't you're not
shipped to siberia they should say i'll
say danny effing k right
f and k
but um well okay listen we're going to
go and thank you so much for the great
tweets we'll be tweeting about if you
want to actually interact with us a
little bit more uh on facebook the live
streams 4 p.m eastern uh every day
monday through thursday we're doing
facebook live stream chats and giving
away stuff so thank you so much uh we're
going to be back and wrap this all up
with the thoughts of the week
blotter with clutter.com hand etched i
just can't get over
[Music]
dad what are you doing here i i want to
go to bed don't bother me i'm sleeping
come on mom's looking for you time to go
home go
you think you could get me one of these
dormio mattresses i'll see what i can do
okay i'm tired
i'm just saying they're they're sponsors
i know just go i'm tired that's not how
this works go i'll see what i can do
hello mattress my old friend
i've come to lay with you again
because of vision i was dreaming
of you and i together sleeping
and the comfort
dormio mattresses
sleepwithcrowder.com for specials and
free shipping and a pillow
[Music]
of silence
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to be back that's pogo
wonderful bumps from pogo that's
original that's pogo singing there for
people who don't know
that is pogo singing this is the last
segment uh at not gay jarrett on the
twitter at uh jordan what's your uh do
you want your twitter handle out there
uh they don't need my twitter okay they
don't need you i don't post anything
interesting no
you mostly just retweet crap you tweet
well listen
if i serve no other purpose
uh we have some big guests coming up in
uh next week your seven day free trial
you're watching this for free lotto with
credit.com mug club if you want the
daily show you get to try for free seven
days like we said listen if only a
couple a couple percentage points of you
people who've enjoyed the content for
free
want to help us fight back we really
appreciate it um
we have about a dozen people who we've
hired now we're growing we want to bring
on some some new people and uh fight
back against the uh the leftist media
establishment hey hey you're fake news
no no no no fake news you're fake news i
want to have that just ready i do
now every time someone said i would just
you fake news fake news on next uh i
think we have mike rowe i think we have
uh i think we might have george simpier
coming up soon george
uh mike huckabee rick santorum on the
political side artie lange
uh
nick apollo of course you have your
regulars so we have we have a lot of
people coming up now not all of them are
here on youtube again some of them are
behind the crtv paywall this program
that you're watching live will be
available
for all time on crtv and on the app
um
so end of the week last segment here's
one thing if there's a takeaway you know
and i do these once a week i don't do
them every single day because it takes
some time for these things to to
percolate
you see it with the fake news and you
see seth meyers has reversed course on
that now
you see with reza oslon dismissing all
of his opponents as bigots
we've seen it with social justice
leftists for a long time who dismiss
everybody who disagree with him as
racist we see everyone telling you how
outrageous it is for steve harvey to
make a joke that was based on someone
accurate statistics it doesn't really
matter because it's a joke
you do not need to let anybody out there
tell you
what should offend you
what causes you need to support what
opinions you need to hold and you
certainly don't need people who are
beholden to you believing that they are
real news telling you what fake news is
you don't need to do that anymore and
that's why we're doing what we're doing
we've really built this i'm incredibly
grateful to everyone the team who's
worked so hard this week i know there's
been some technical glitches but we're
able now to bypass these filters
and i don't want you to take what i tell
you and accept it we get tweets all the
time from people disagreeing with us
telling us that we're wrong and we
appreciate it we issue retractions or
corrections we just did this week
on an article i don't have a problem
with it because i don't need you to
believe that i'm right all the time we
just want you to be able to go out and
at least parse through just cut through
some of the bs
and and i hope we've helped you with
that but because everybody else is
telling you the whether it's msnbc cnn
or even fox news of course the young
turks reza oslon whether it's huffpo
with steve harvey's joke
they're trying to tell this is what you
need to think this is how you need to
feel
you don't
now here's the beauty we've talked about
this on this show okay
um when we do this show the best shows
and listen there's a discrepancy as
there always is sometimes you have good
days at work sometimes you have off days
the best shows that we do here everyone
in this room i know not gj we've agreed
is where we have done a ton of prep
and we know the statistics and we have
the information at hand and we have it
in our show run down
that's actually when we're the loosest
and we have the most fun in the room
because we know what we're saying is
airtight when we have a guest drop out
or we have to scramble at the end of the
day where we don't feel quite as
prepared that's actually when it's most
tense here you would think it's the
opposite where if you prep too much
you're kind of staccato let me tell you
and this is important for everyone if
you're going into college if you're
going into an industry where people tend
to lean left if you have to join a union
card check where they want you to lean
left
being prepared i don't want to ever tell
you how to think certainly not what to
feel
your bs meter should do
anytime someone says that we never want
to do that
but you will find that you are most
fluid in your critical thinking and your
ability to articulate your points and
your ability to convert other people to
your way of thinking when you are so
prepared and you have information from
every source available i encourage you
to go to huffpo i encourage you to go to
salon i encourage you to watch msnbc i
even encourage you to listen to oslon or
seth meyers who now want to tell you
that they're not about fake news because
they ran nothing but fake news i
encourage it because when you hear what
they have to say and then you hear the
other side as you do when you watch this
program well actually you hear both
sides in this program we bring a lot of
left just so we'll have our booker come
in it's been really hard to get them to
come on this show they don't they they
they see what happens and a lot of them
don't want to come back but when you
prepare yourself and you use all you
take advantage of all the information
that you have available you will find
you are more fluid and you're looser in
the shoulders on your punches in
everyday life because you're confident
in that you know what's going on and so
people who tell you you you you need to
think this all of my opponents are
bigots you should be offended by this
joke that's a stiffness right their
arguments aren't fluid it's gotten tired
the left everything is racist
everything's transphobic everything's
homophobic right right that's why people
voted for donald trump they're not
getting away with it anymore their
arguments are so stiff they only have
it's like it's like a fighter with one
tool they've only got that right hand
why because they haven't done their prep
the left doesn't have the information as
you see with buzzfeed as you see with
cnn and when you don't have the
information when you're not informed
when you're not educated you tend to
rely on one argument and you get really
stressed and stiff
so what i want to see is the opposite
from anyone who watches or listens to
this program i want you to saturate
yourself with news not only news
philosophy theology if you believe in in
god whatever your religion is i want you
to saturate yourself with it so you know
so much and you feel so confident in
your ability to be informed that you
don't have to rely on an argument like
someone's racist and you certainly never
have to tell somebody else exactly what
they need to think or how they feel
because that's
not what we do and that that's not what
anyone should do
who believes in their position
that's not what anyone should do who
believes in their argument whenever
someone sticks with one whenever someone
is stiff whenever someone's
not quite comfortable and you see that
with with azalea you see that with seth
meyers and they're gonna stick
they're not prepared so that's hopefully
what we've helped with hopefully what
the daily show helps with um
just be prepared and that's not hard to
do everyone can do it
see you next week
[Music]
you